know from previous videos that the
derivative with respect to X of the
natural log of X natural log of X is
equal to 1 over X what I want to do in
this video is use that knowledge that
we've seen in other videos to figure out
what the derivative with respect to X is
of a logarithm of an arbitrary base so
I'm just going to call that log base a
of X so how do we figure this out
well the key thing is is what you might
be familiar with from your algebra or
your precalculus classes which is having
a change of base so if I have some I'll
do it over here log base a of B and I
want to change it to a different base
let's say I want to change it to base C
this is the same thing as log base C of
B divided by log base log base C of a
log base C of B divided by log base C of
a and this is a really useful thing if
you've never seen it before you now have
just seen it this change of base and we
proved it in other videos on Khan
Academy but it's really useful because
for example your calculator has a log
button but the log on your calculator is
log base 10 so if you do log if you
press 10 and you're 100 into your
calculator and press log you will get a
2 there so whenever you just see log of
100 it's implicitly base 10 and you also
have a button for natural log which is
log base E natural log of X is equal to
log base E of X and but sometimes you
want to find all sorts of different of
based logarithms and this is how you do
it so if you're using your calculator
and you wanted to find of if you wanted
to find what log base 3 of 8 is you
would say you would type in your
calculator log of 8 + log of 3 or let me
write it this way and log of 3 where
both of these are implicitly base 10 and
get the same value if you did natural
log of eight divided by natural log of
three which you might also have on your
calculator and we're going to do in this
video is leverage is leverage the
natural log because we know what the
derivative of the natural log is so this
derivative is the same thing as the
derivative with respect to X of well log
base a of X can be rewritten as natural
log of x over natural log of a and now
natural log of a that's just a number I
could rewrite this I could rewrite this
as write this way 1 over natural log of
a times natural log of X and what's the
derivative of that well we could just
take the constant out 1 over natural
rate that's just a number so we're going
to get 1 over the natural log of a times
the derivative times the derivative with
respect to X of natural log of X of
natural log of X which we already know
is 1 over X so this thing right over
here is 1 over X so what we get is 1
over natural log of a times 1 over X
which we could write as 1 over natural
log of a times X times X which is a
really useful thing to know so now we
could take all sorts of all sorts of
derivatives so if I were to tell you f
of X is equal to log base 7 of X well
now we could say well F prime of X is
going to be 1 over the natural log of 7
times X if we had a constant out front
if we had for example G of X G of X is
equal to negative 3 times log base I
don't know log base pi pi is the number
log base PI of X
well G prime of X would be equal to one
over the or let me be careful I have
this constant out here so it'd be
negative three over it's just that
negative three over the natural log of
Pi so this is the natural log of this
number times X so hopefully that gives
you a hang of things